which one of your papers are you most
proud of
there's as far as i can see there are
three at least referenced in your thesis
i'm gonna read them out loud quantum
advantage of unitary clifford circuits
with magic state
inputs the one clean qubit model without
entanglement is classically simulable
and a condition under which classical
simulability
implies efficient state learnability so
which one of those
do you think is the most significant 100
think it's the the middle one um it's
the
uh that um the one clean qubit model
without entanglement is classically
simulable
uh that that was the result basically
that i started a phd to get
um i and and also
the result that i very nearly didn't get
um despite spending years on it
i maybe spent five years on that that
single topic
um so yeah uh why
it was such a big deal is yeah there's
this very
interesting hypothesis in quantum
computing
that entanglement is the main ingredient
of a quantum computer that somehow it's
like
the the weird bit of quantum mechanics
that like a quantum computer is taking
advantage of
to get all these speed ups is
entanglement
and um like yeah it's a very
sort of dominant uh like ideology in
quantum computing um despite the fact
that like yeah there's
it hasn't been proved either way um and
like the evidence for it is like i would
say fairly weak
um so evidently that evidence that
entanglement does have something to do
or doesn't have something to do
that it does um like i'd say it's i mean
it's not
maybe weak is the wrong term like it's
just like it's not a strong case it's
suggestive but it's not a strong case
um so like my supervisor and uh
um like his co-author a long time ago
have proved
um that if you have no entanglement
inside of your quantum computer
like your errorless quantum computer
then you get something that's
classically simulable which is very
suggestive
that that entanglement's important right
um but there were some reasons why
um this may like
not sort of extend nicely um one is that
that it works when you have zero
entanglement but it doesn't work well
when you have like a a small but not
zero amount of entanglement like what
you would expect
is similar to what i was saying about
the goddess mcniel theorem you would
expect that like
as you increase the entanglement it
becomes harder and harder to
classically simulate that that result
has never been shown
um and in fact probably
i i suspect it can't be shown exactly by
the way when you say it gets harder and
harder to show that it gets
classically simulated why is it not just
it is classically simulable or not why
is it that there's a continuum
yeah okay so um when we say something's
easy to classically simulate we mean
it's polynomial when it's hard it's
exponential but
if the exponential is so like let's say
uh there's some parameter like the
amount of entanglement or the number of
t gates there's some parameter like that
um where the cost of classically
simulating
this um quantum computer scales with
that term so it's like e to the power of
that term then it suggests that like as
you add more of that thing it's getting
harder and harder
i say yeah okay um yeah so
uh so you're one qubit clean model yeah
okay yeah so um the
entanglement case hadn't been shown well
even for um like what we call pure state
quantum computers and so these are the
sort of idealized quantum computers that
have no noise in them
but um real quantum computers have noise
in them
and you might think okay but that's like
not sort of mathematically relevant like
okay that's relevant for engineers but
who cares about that from the maths
point of view
but actually from math point of view
these like noisy quantum computers are
super super interesting because
they they have like very different
mathematics and like
much more complicated and sort of um
like in a way that the where where like
i'm almost skeptical of results that are
approved only for pure state quantum
computers and not for mixed state
quantum computers
because it it feels like that might just
be a quirk whereas like the real thing
is these noisy things
um and so like no result like that had
been proved for noisy quantum computers
so like the result you would want is
um without any entanglement for a noisy
quantum computer
there is no uh like if if you have no
um entanglement in a noisy quantum
computer you have no quantum advantage
that would be the result that like we
would love to show is true or false
um and so i had started this project
kind of trying to come up with a counter
example
i wanted to find a noisy quantum
computer that had no entanglement
that still had a quantum advantage um
and so
uh there was like a very good candidate
there's something called the one clean
qubit model
and it's like really fascinating
basically it's a quantum computer
that has one cubit that is
um like clean or pure um and what
what that really means is we know
exactly what state it's in and then you
have
um the rest of the qubits in that
quantum computer
are completely dirty in other words like
we have no idea what they're doing they
could be doing anything
um and usually if you have like a set of
just like dirty cubits
you can't do anything with them because
like if you don't know anything and you
do something to them then you still
don't know anything right
but adding this like one qubit where you
do know what's happening
like completely changes this model so um
it's like remarkable but like yeah you
have this one
qubit you know and all these computes
where you don't know anything you
do some processing to it and then you
measure something at the end that is
actually genuinely useful
and can like solve some like problems
that
appear to be classically hard to solve
uh so
so that's the one click qubit model but
the thing that was very interesting
about it and why it made it a good
like candidate for me to study was that
um there's this result
that the one clean qubit and the rest of
those noisy qubits
never become entangled with each other
despite like throughout the whole
computation
which like is very strange because you
like
you know the one cleveland cupid is
clearly somehow the one that's like
giving its quantum power to the rest of
the rest of the cubits who have no power
so you would expect that if there's
communication between those two sets
that it would be via entanglement if
entanglement is important
um and so like the fact that there's no
entanglements like very suggestive that
there's something else going on
and so i wanted to study the one clean
qubit model where there's no
entanglement
not just between those two qubits those
like this the clean cubits are all noisy
ones
but within the noisy ones there's no
entanglement within them as well
um so like no entanglement across any of
the qubits like none of the qubits were
allowed to talk to each other
that way um and
yeah what i found was that um
like yeah we we were studying this this
topic for a long time and i was very
very convinced
that this quantum computer with no
entanglement would have
like some quantum advantage because it
was very complicated and
if it's complicated it suggests that
it's hard to classically simulate which
suggests it's doing something that's
like genuinely quantum
um but like yeah after a few years of
working on it
um it suddenly occurred to me that i
could i could classically simulate it
like i
figured out what the algorithm was and
it was a huge process from that point
to like actually writing down the
algorithm for sure but
um but yeah like it uh
it really like surprised me because i
thought i was going to prove the
opposite thing um
right right fact that we proved this
instead
actually makes me quite convinced now
that entanglement is important